francia vive el fin de la abundancia y
también de la irresponsabilidad con esas
palabras poco optimistas recibe el
presidente manuel macro a sus ministros
en este primer consejo de gabinete a un
mensaje en directo también para los
franceses pues el año que comienza se
prevé complicado primero en el área
internacional el conflicto en ucrania
sigue y tiene consecuencias para el
bolsillo de los franceses sobre todo por
la crisis energética por eso durante sus
vacaciones
emanuel macro mantuvo los contactos con
su homólogo ucraniano o ruso pero
también con los líderes de eeuu de
alemania y del reino unido pero también
a nivel interno el gobierno de manuel
macrón está siendo presionado durante
este verano los franceses vivieron en
carne propia las consecuencias del
calentamiento global tuvieron sequía
incendios forestales olas de calor y una
tormenta mortal en la isla de córcega
por lo que el gobierno está presionado
para acelerar la transición energética
presentará un proyecto de ley en el
otoño la semana que viene los ministros
irán a un seminario al respecto y la
primera ministra hablará de sobriedad en
la universidad de los empresarios si no
hay otros temas importantes complicados
de tratar como son la reforma a las
pensiones del seguro de desempleo para
hacer más difícil el acceso a las ayudas
son a medios que el gobierno de manuel
macro no utilizará para ahorrar dinero
pero que son polémicos y lo enfrentarán
con los sindicatos y también con los
parlamentarios de las nubes la alianza
de izquierda recordemos el gobierno ya
no tiene la mayoría en la asamblea
nacional otro tema complicado el
presupuesto de este año por ahora se
especula que el gobierno de manuel macro
no lo aprobará a través de decreto